[Music]
it's so
natural for a person to retort to anger
and so that's exactly where she goes and
it's that always being there it's what's
drived her
throughout everything i
guess i didn't see
particularly that danny would just fire
bomb the city there's a part of tyrion
at that moment
that completely dies it's a really weird
relationship that they have and i think
it's a really weird
thing for him to
process here comes that familiar feeling
of anger and she doesn't do anything to
choke that she
lives in it
it doesn't matter where you stand it's a
horrific thing
um and i guess john and dan danny stand
on opposite ends of the spectrum on that
one
it's this feeling that you could call
targaryen craziness you could give it
all of these names that it doesn't
deserve because it is just
grief
it's hard
and she has this ability to make that
hurt a little bit less just for a minute
and here she is sitting on this ridge
and there's the emotion and there's the
feeling and the feeling is to [ __ ]
kill her sorry
i don't think that grey worm can ever
really see
as the mad queen
to him she actually has a very clear
sense of what's right and what's wrong
the final thing for john is seeing
innocent people killed and his own men
start to go and rape
women
kill innocent civilians loot pillage
and he can't stop them this isn't a fair
fight this isn't honor
it's the moment that john cheats his
sword you can follow me or you can carry
on
but i'm going this is i'm backing out of
this it didn't have to happen
they were ready to surrender
and if she had just held out a little
longer everything would have been fine
when you when you feel that much when
you feel that much failure and
disappointment and shame and hurt and
lost love
there's only so much pain you can handle
before you snap
[Music]